I want to start today with a correction
if I get something wrong or if I'm not
clear or if I'm incomplete about
something I always try to do these at
the top of the show I have no intention
of hiding the corrections on the back
page so to speak as is often the case
with newspapers or other Publications
um so let me get right into that
yesterday I did this segment about Fox
News propagandist Tucker Carlson siding
with Vladimir Putin and sort of writing
off Ukraine saying Ukraine isn't even a
democracy and sort of softly justifying
or defending or excusing Vladimir
Putin's invasion of Ukraine and I made a
lot of critiques of Ukraine in that
segment that are true including that
there are concerns in Ukraine about
women's rights there is corruption in
Ukraine there's a lack of true rule of
law in Ukraine number of other
concerning elements in Ukraine but I
didn't make clear that Tucker is wrong
about Ukraine not being a democracy
Ukraine is a democracy more or less and
certainly way more than Russia is if you
look at the freedom index
freedomhouse.org you'll see that Ukraine
is a 60 out of a hundred on the freedom
index which is sort of a measure of
democracy uh Russia is a 20. so 60 puts
Ukraine as partly free 20 puts Russia as
not free so if I didn't make clear or I
misstated Ukraine is a democracy albeit
a flawed one and Ukraine is moving in
the direction of being more democratic
whereas recently Russia has moved in the
direction of being less Democratic
um the Ukrainian president zielinski
genuinely won an election a real
election he's in over his head for sure
there were some problems with the
election but it was he won he he won uh
he did not control the election in the
way that Vladimir Putin controls
elections in Russia
um and so this is a correction I didn't
make that clear yesterday zielinski is
not an authoritarian autocrat Vladimir
Putin is and that is a crucial
difference between Russia and Ukraine it
doesn't resolve any other issue it
doesn't excuse the things that are not
okay in Ukraine uh but I appreciate the
opportunity to make that correction